Speaker 1: We're starting today with a story that
comes to us from the the poorest country in the
Western Hemisphere, the country of Haiti, where
the Haitian president was assassinated in his home
early yesterday morning. The New York Times
has a very good article summing this up called
Haiti's president assassinated in a nighttime raid
shaking a fragile nation. A group of assailants
stormed Mr. Moises residence early on Wednesday,
shooting him and wounding his wife. The interim
prime minister declaring a state of siege. The
first explosions took place around 1:00 a.m.
and this took place at the home of President Jovan
Elmore's. And this is a wealthy neighborhood.
Residents immediately feared two of the terrors
that have plagued the nation, gang violence or an
earthquake. But by the morning, they had learned
that the president was dead. A group of assailants
had stormed Mr. Mozes residency on the outskirts
of the capital, Port au Prince, early Wednesday,
shooting him and wounding his wife. Martine was
in what officials called a well planned operation
that included foreigners who spoke Spanish.
Much is being made of the Spanish aspect of it,
although it's really too early to know too much
about what that means. In a televised broadcast
to the nation, the nation's interim prime
minister, Claude Joseph, appealed for calm and
presented himself as the new head of government,
announcing that he and his fellow ministers had
declared a state of siege and placed Haiti under
a form of martial law. The assassination left a
political void that deepened the turmoil and
violence that has gripped Haiti for months,
threatening to tip one of the world's most
troubled nations further into lawlessness.
You know, I'm not sure how much people in the
audience know about the history of Haiti. Haiti
is on a landmass that is an island that is shared
with another country, the Dominican Republic,
Haiti in the east and the Dominican Republic
I'm sorry, Haiti in the west and the Dominican
Republic to the east. The island is called
Espanola. And there are really, really
racist, crude, quote, explanations that are
given for why. OK, the Dominican Republic is
not a wealthy country, but it is significantly
better off than Haiti, which is the poorest
country in the West. And you maybe you can imagine
what that racist analysis is. But it's quite the
simple. Haiti is black people, whereas the
Dominican Republic is Latino folks often of
with more of of European origin. I mean, that's
the that's the white nationalist sort of crude
racist explanation for the disparity between
Haiti and the Dominican Republic economically
and in other ways. Now, this is actually
something that's been studied extensively.
Jared Diamond in his book Collapse, which I read
just not too long ago, actually talks a lot about
it. And when you understand the differences
in Haiti and the Dominican Republic, including
the placement of Haiti in the West and the
Dominican Republic in the east, and what
that means in terms of current, what that means in
terms of rainfall, elevation, early deforestation
happening in Haiti due to lack of other natural
resources, you really start to understand that
there's a very complex situation, in fact, in
the country. And unfortunately, this has led to
a situation of significant instability in Haiti,
political problems, environmental degradation
and so many other things. And now this on top
of it, just a horrible, horrible situation.
The New York Times adding the details of who
shot the president and why he remained unknown
for people suspected of being involved in the
assassination, were killed by the police in a
gun battle and two others were arrested, Haiti's
police chief said late yesterday. The chief, Leon
Charles, also said that three police officers who
had been held hostage were freed. The authorities
did not name any of the suspects or cite any
evidence linking them to the assassination. The
other thing I think that's important to mention is
there were some early mentions of the assailants
claimed to be DEA. Now, the American DEA, the Drug
Enforcement Agency, does have a presence in Haiti.
And there it's it's still so early that there
were some folks who immediately said, oh,
the DEA carried this out. Every indication so
far is that the assailants falsely claimed to be
DEA agents. There is no evidence at this time
that the DEA carried out this assassination.
This doesn't mean that the U.S., CIA, through the
CIA and other agencies, hasn't been involved in
political assassinations in the past. That's not
what it means. It just means in this case, there
is no evidence that that's that's the reality.
All we know is that the assailants claimed to
be DEA agents based on one report. So we're going
to continue following this. Of course, the hope is
that Haiti does not devolve into even more chaos
and instability because that's the last thing
that the Haitian people need. There have already
been some questions about will the U.S. help? And
I know that that makes a lot of people very,
very scared of what does it mean when the U.S.
helps in the Caribbean, in Central America and
in Latin America. And I get that. But let's let's
keep our analysis based on what is known rather
than what is hypothesized or speculated at this
point in time. And hopefully in the next two to
three days, there's going to be more clarity there